The first season was about a theme park now
it's about a very, very dangerous environment
the fantasy is become reality.
The gloves of come off can be hurt killed they're locked in with the hosts.
the stakes have risen dramatically, should be a lot of fun.
hey Youtubers, it's Charlie.
This is going to be my Westworld season two
predictions also have a little bit of a teaser
to give us an idea for the course the season
to the gonna take.
So just careful for spoilers if you haven't
seen season one of Westworld.
there is a new round of the giveaway that
starts now.
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video be sure
to click that bell to enable alerts so you
don't miss anything during the off-season,
so these aren't in any particular order.
But some things we actually know their confirm
like that little teaser that the Nolan's gave,
so number one the Nolan said that order was
the theme of season one the Westworld people
trying to keep order behind-the-scenes than
try to keep the park running trying to keep
the senti and hosts from rising up rolling
them back when they did, so they said season
two is going to be defined by chaos, so that
just means chaos in all the different areas
that they visit.
So you have chaos in the parks sentient host
rising up doing as they please chaos behind
the scenes on the board.
So you have people like the man in black might
be at odds with the other board members who
want to keep the senti and hosts from rising
up.
He wants them to continue to exist.
So he might clash with them and then chaos
amongst the technicians people like Felix
who want to help the senti and hosts as opposed
to the other technicians they're just trying
to do their job and keep their heads down
just try it up for the show film them and
see the urgency so as you talk about to the
host along in flash one.
So whereas before they wanted Westworld to
seem like it was this well oiled machine,
everybody in every different places going
to be a complete mess is going to make for
great drama next big one samurai world or
Shogun world.
Depending on how you want to think about it
whatever that S means when Felix said it's
complicated that just means that they didn't
want to explain the producers didn't want
to explain before they completely figured
out the concept.
So it just means that another park is going
to be the setting for season two.
It won't be set inside Westworld will explore
the idea of multiple parks shogun world is
just one of those there could be many parks
beyond that and here's the thing that really
seals the deal, HBO had a website for Westworld
during season one called explore Westworld
will he just had additional content just for
poking around mythology on the show and recently
they just registered the domains explore samurai
world and explore Shogun world.com so that
just confirms that were going to be going
to those places, but again that doesn't mean
that that's the only place that will see you
just means that it will be one of the biggest
places.
So they did say that each season.
They just wanted to build a bunch of awesome
sets should an awesome story then burn it
all to the ground and go somewhere else.
Meaning that in season three will go to another
park.
So will just keep going to different parks
each new season which it sounds awesome.
So next big thing Maeve found out about her
daughter was in park one like this location
here.
So was probably going to happen is is that
her daughter will wind up in a different park
outside of Westborough like they reassigned
her to another narrative.
So hopefully Maeve in the other senti and
hosts will go to this other park for reasons
of their own like they will be looking for
her daughter.
The other hosts might fully trying to hide
from the board members.
There's a whole bunch of questions about what's
going to happen to the senti and hosts that
were involved in the massacre the big red
wedding.
They had at the end of the season maybe they'll
be assigned to this other park with the new
narrative.
The next big thing.
Speaking of red wedding board is probably
going to actually be dead even though his
presence will continue to be felt like it
Obi wan or Yoda force ghost.
So he won't physically be a big part of the
plot of season two but the specter of what
he set in motion will still be very present.
So people will continue to talk about him
talk about the old man, especially Bernard
next big prediction who will sort of take
over the role that Ford had in programming
all the host because it's still a huge endeavor
there still a whole bunch of other parks that
are operating somebody has to keep that running.
So nobody in the position of authority that
could challenge him knows that Bernard is
a host.
So he'll probably be promoted and try to balance
the senti and hosts try to help them out while
at the same time keeping the board debate
and keeping all the parks running.
So next big one a new main villain will rise
from the bellows board.
Maybe one of the new members that selected
to fill the seat of one of the dead members
because they had all the board members there.
Maybe not every single one, but most of them
were killed in that red wedding incident.
Meaning that giant corporation has a bunch
of empty board seats to fill.
So maybe Charles dance is available or someone
like him can fill one of those seats and become
the villain of the season so that the man
in black who continues to be somewhat of like
a gray area not really good not really evil
but still a terrible person doesn't have to
be the main villain himself.
So again, the thing about the man in black
is that he got what he wanted.
He wants the senti and host to continue to
exist so he can have to do something to protect
them he's the chairman of the board he controls
the majority of the Corporation that doesn't
mean that he's completely invincible.
So even though he is a terrible human being
there still people on the board that could
try to ouster him who are only interested
in money whereas he wants to experience something
that's truly real.
So he loves what happened at the end of the
season and he wants to see that continue another
big one they'll confirm the location of Westworld,
which is probably on an island is because
May's protocol was to invade the mainland
that she chose to ignore that to go back and
find her daughter so mainland implies that
Westworld is on an island somewhere near another
nation, so that doesn't necessarily mean that
it's near the United States or its near China.
But it could just be localized to where ever
that genre is so like Westworld is largely
an American thing, so that could exist near
America Shogun world could be somewhere else
or could be like a series of islands near
each other so this could be like somewhere
in the Pan Pacific area, but keep in mind
that Westworld is hundreds of square miles.
The other parks are probably about the same
size, so that have to be very big island so
there aren't that many places where you could
put these parks speaking of dead people.
People coming back the biggest returning characters
are probably going to be the man in black,
just because Ed Harris confirmed that he was
coming back.
Dolores Teddy Maeve Felix Bernard the Hemsworth
brother who is missing in action he'll probably
come back at some point and maybe some armistice
to lease for little while you think that they
would try to decommission the hose that were
super murderous, but because the way Ford
turned off the security protocols I think
there's a way they could explain armistice
getting out of that situation.
Even though she doesn't have an arm right
now but the last big one is the premier date.
So everybody has probably heard that, because
they're taking so long to develop the season.
Work on the scripts not gonna start shooting
till next summer.
Meaning that it won't premier till sometime
in 2018 that could be the beginning of 2018
that could be sometime during the summer or
it could be.
During this time, depending on how long they
hold it was much of a bummer is that is they're
just trying to avoid a true Detective season
two situation whereby you have this really
awesome season of TV followed up by Billy
crappy season just because they rush it and
have terrible scripts.
They don't have enough time to work on the
stories to make them really good.
So that's the main reason why they're taking
their time in making season to meaning that
season two is going to be amazing.
I think it's going to be even better than
season one that actually had to stop production
in the middle of season one to take extra
time to finish the last couple of scripts
they changed a whole much of story points
the original ending they had in mind when
they shot the pilot was different from the
ending that they chose to go with at the end
of the season so they had like a much better
idea midway through they had a whole production
to fix that.
So I think they're trying to prevent that
from happening during season two, so they
get all their ducks in a row and they can
shoot it will be amazing, but it will be a
while before it gets here will still do bonus
videos we have game of thrones coming before
then.
So the be giveaways going on the be all kinds
of stuff, so let me know in the comments what
are all your predictions about Westworld season
two and what kind of bonus videos do you want
me to do while we wait for it to get here.
There's so much time that there will be a
lot of bonus videos I'll probably do a video
about the Ford is a host or was a host in
the finale theory.
I don't necessarily think that it's true but
it's an interesting theory to talk about,
so I'll probably do a video for that is there
any other theories that you guys want to suggest
just write them in the comments I'll say congratulations
to this week's Westworld giveaway winner Drogon
you and a $20 Amazon gift card be sure to
private message me on the back and my channel
so I can get your contact details so I've
already started a new round, I'll announce
the winner the next time I post a Westworld
bonus video next week what's can happen next
is I'll post a trailer video for the rest
of the season on walking dead the board he
released the trailer for the next episode,
so that should post pretty soon to there will
be a flash bonus video and I'll be doing another
Rick and Morty video really soon too while
you guys wait for that to post you can click
here for all my Westworld videos and you can
click here for my walking dead finale video
think you so much watching everybody high
five I'll see you guys tonight!